he hasn't been in the ring with rocky in
a while but he's still pretty busy
here's what cold weathers has been up to
since his iconic turn as Apollo Creed
what are you thinking
weathers poked fun at his most famous
post Apollo roll and Saturday Night Live
in 2003 reminding everyone that he will
indeed be forever remembered in the
popular imagination as the black guy in
predator 1987's predator was first and
foremost an Arnold Schwarzenegger film
but it was a big deal for weathers at
the time proving he could be a
formidable presence on the big screen
with or without Sylvester Stallone at
his side which is likely why he soon
found himself headlining his own action
film 1988 action Jackson could have lost
weathers into superstardom as a first
film when a lucrative action franchise
but the film's failing production
company was sold off and the film was
universally panned primarily for
dialogue like this barbeque huh how do
you like your ribs
but whether sad high hopes he told
bullseye in 2009
yeah people loved action Jackson I get
asked all the time are you ever going to
do a sequel I still maintain today that
it could have been a better movie have
we taken a little bit longer to develop
the screenplay but a lot of people liked
it in Germany it was huge
we're the straightest hand at being an
action star once again in 1992 s
hurricane Smith think a low-rent action
Jackson sat in Australia but it wasn't
huge anywhere and it's best summed up by
the alternate international title dead
on delivery
weathers wasn't necessarily known for
his comedy skills when his agent steered
him toward Adam Sandler in 1996 but
weathers soon found himself in sunless
happy gilmore playing chubbs Peterson a
former pro golfer who was forced into
retirement after an alligator bit off
his hand tall one of that bastard's eyes
looking pretty sick chaps the
performance showed the world a different
side of weathers which led to further
comedy roles including on one of the
best sitcoms of all time although he's
only appeared in a grand total of four
episodes over the course of the five
seasons so far of Arrested Development
weathers relish the opportunity to get a
little goofy by playing an exaggerated
version of himself there's still plenty
meat on that bone you take this home
throw it in a pot add some broth the
potato did you get a stew gone series
create submit show her words had
originally contemplated going in a
different direction with bizarro call
mum which could have involved a parody
of rocky and Apollo's Beach run in Rocky
3 but when he asked weathers if he had
any thoughts whether suggested that
maybe he could be really cheap instead
Hurwitz told vulture it was so much
better I went back to the writers room
and said you're not gonna believe this
cold weathers wants to be incredibly
cheap all credit to call on that after
his career in the NFL but before he
became king of the morning shows Michael
Strahan took a shot at sitcom stardom
with Fox's brothers weathers played
straight hands dad and told The Times
Picayune in advance of the show's
September 2009 premiere you see a
contemporary black family that expresses
itself with a bit of edge it's an edgy
show but at the same time you see the
love unfortunately the love wasn't
shared by the viewing public by the end
of December folks had already bid adieu
to the brothers if you're an old-school
cable box channel surfer
you've likely spotted weathers popping
up on plenty of shows from voicework on
the Cartoon Network to character roles
and award show appearances all across
the dial
after spending a season playing Josh
Holloway's partner on USA's colony
weathers added a new series regular
credit to his name in 2017 introduced a
state's attorney Mark Jeffries in an
episode of NBC's Chicago PD he reprised
the role in Chicago justice and an
episode of Law & Order SVU that isn't
the only role keeping him busy lately
either weathers also popped up in an
early episode of CBS's rebooted magnum
p.i in 2018
[Music]